the Orville will return for a fourth
series Disney are getting ready to green
like the project welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
when the Orville first came to our
screens I adored it I thought it was
absolutely brilliant and I thought it
was a bit of a love letter to Star Trek
there was always these rumors that Seth
MacFarlane definitely wanted to make a
Star Trek series but wasn't allowed so
he thought it I'll make my own Dr
aaronov this is my security chief of
Lara Katan my chief medical officer
Claire Finn pleasure and my ex-wife
Kelly Grayson and in lots of ways it was
more comedy than sci-fi what is that it
appears to be a Class 2 spatial fold
back at Union Point we called that a
glory hole you called it a glory hole
nobody else called it a glory hole no
entering [ __ ] no borders it's not
it's well as we went through the first
two seasons it matured slightly and we
saw by the end of the second season a
lot less of the screwball Family Guy
humor and more of actual proper science
fiction if you like the design this is
available on side ashtrak.com you can
even buy Stargate box please go and give
it a look also if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit the
Bell notification it really helps us out
and if you enjoy the content don't
forget to become a fully fledged side
tracker and hit that join Button as well
as subscribe into sides our sister
Channel all of the links are in the
description
when we got into New Horizons it had
really grown up into one of the best
science fiction shows on TV right now a
lot of people have argued and still
argued that actually the best Star Trek
series on TV right now is the Orville
and
it's not an argument I'd want to get
into because strange new worlds was
Bloody good but at the same time the
oval is much better than most of
everything else that's out there
so news has come to me through a few
sources that I speak to that Disney Hulu
are about to green light a new series
McFarland seems to have sort of
underlined this with some of his tweet
recently saying that he's still waiting
on news but I don't know the tone of his
tweets if that's a possible thing does
sound quite positive but the sources
that I speak to have said that there
have been a few obstacles in the path
even though Disney and Hulu are very
keen to push forward with the Orville it
would have to be with a slightly smaller
budget New Horizons was a massive Step
Up in budget for the Orville and you
could see that on the screen I mean and
more than one occasion the oval was
actually mocked for its special effects
because they weren't much better than
the next generation's special effects
from 30 years ago and Seth MacFarlane
put his hand up and said no we didn't
get the budget we were hoping for I'm
thinking in one particular episode I
think it was the second season
um there was something where the author
went into a two-dimensional space the
special effects for that were genuinely
embarrassing
it looked like Tron from like 1980
it was it was pretty bad but the special
effects Etc and the general ambition of
the show in Orville New Horizons was
definitely in a different League the
battle sequences on their own were some
of the best in sci-fi that we've seen
for a very long time and I'm a sucker
for a good space battle
yeah
so why are we still waiting a few months
after well actually the numbers for the
Orville were pretty good the premiere
numbers the problem is they weren't
necessarily as good as Disney and Hulu
hoped even though this broke some of
their records the numbers just didn't
quite match the budget
however with streaming services the
actual initial figures aren't the whole
story streaming services are very very
interested in any new viewers they pick
up so viewers that have not watched the
Orville now that it's on Disney plus
before so if the show picks up a new
growing audience they're really
interested in those sort of numbers but
they're also really interested in
re-watch numbers how many people will
watch this show more than once because
for them that is almost as important as
the premiere numbers on their own and
according to my source the numbers for
the re-watches have been phenomenal
Disney are very very happy that this
show is one of those shows that they
kind of love because there's a loyal
audience to it people will subscribe to
Disney Plus at least in part to watch
the Orville it's not one of the shows
that people will just watch because it's
there they will actually go and find it
is there some reason I am the central
focus of everyone's attention because a
show even with a small but loyal
audience is worth its weight in gold
this is really similar to why I argue
that Warner Brothers is actually really
pushing to get Babylon 5 onto hbr Max
rather than letting it go to the CW
because again Babylon 5 is one of those
shows that people will follow they will
subscribe to HBO Max to watch the show
they will watch other stuff while
they're there hopefully
the loyal fan base will follow a show
and grow subscribers for HBO Max so
Disney are in this place now where
they're very very happy with the numbers
on the whole but the premiere numbers
were not what they were hoping for so
they've been negotiating with the
production company and in part with Seth
MacFarlane and they're simply saying
look we want to make the show but we
need to get the budget down a little bit
she's clearly asking her friend where to
find the nearest repair service for her
device but instead of writing Wireless
telecommunications facility she just
wrote WTF we spent too much money on New
Horizons and we didn't really get the
viewing figures we were hoping for based
on that budget so let's make a series
four but let's reign in the cost a
little bit now I don't think that's
going to be a massive problem there are
lots of ways that they can spend a
little less money go back to a little
bit more character driven and a few less
Space Battles
and I would argue as well that even
though the Orville New Horizon series
finished on a really nice note that if
it is the last of the Orville that you
know it was a decent end to the Sears
there are lots more questions that a
season four could answer and let's just
pray and hope that the final decision
and the final negotiations go smoothly
and that we hopefully will get all of
them back in our screens in late 2023
but guys get in the comments tell me
what you think is the Orville show that
you would go to Disney plus to watch is
it one of those shows that you will
follow even if it went to a different
Channel I'd love to know exactly what
you think get into the comments if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and if you enjoy the
content and you want to become a fully
fledged side Trekker hit the join button
below
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
give me the device human or I will
destroy your ship sorry can you can you
move like two steps to your right what
it's like a little time it's just a lot
of dead space there just yeah just write
the perfect yeah sorry you were just
very weirdly framed it was all I can
focus on
[Music]